[Music]
bill skarsgard has been working as an
actor since 2000 with some of his
earliest roles including a small role in
a film called whitewater fury in 2000
and a two-episode arc on a mini-series
called laura trenta dad the policeman in
2002. both of which are swedish projects
a decade later he began his run as a
main cast member on the horror series
hemlock grove which went on to have
three total seasons however it was his
role as pennywise the clown in the 2017
film adaptation of stephen king's it
that really brought public attention to
the swedish actor since then skarsgard
has starred in season 1 of the horror
anthology series castle rock in 2018
reprised his role as pennywise for its
chapter 2 in 2019 and acted in a string
of films including 9 days and the devil
all the time
both of which came out in 2020 he also
voiced the character of crow for
marvel's eternals which came out in late
2021 the actor also has quite a few
upcoming projects including john wick
chapter 4 and a tv drama called clark in
which the youngest skarsgard brother
plays the titular character a charming
yet infamous swedish gangster clearly
skarsgard has a lot on his plate but
were he to find the time to play the
part there is one iconic character that
one pop culture fan has in mind for him
and it's the joker artist william gray
who describes himself on instagram as a
quote creator of pop culture inspired
photoshop pieces has made bill skarsgard
a frequent figure in his reimaginings of
popular character actors depicted as
gotham's notorious clown prince of crime
in recent months skarsgard has appeared
nearly a dozen times on the artist's
grid shown in various costumes and
makeup looks in each stunning rendering
the end results have proved that the
actor could make a terrifying version of
the villainous character one of the more
recent pictures depicts a skarsgard
joker being carted hannibal lecter style
into arkham asylum one look at the
comments of the photos and it is crystal
clear that movie fans are on board for
skarsgard as the joker with the first
photo one user wrote
holy sh that actually looks perfect in
my opinion
another user chimed in complete with the
fire emoji well you are a genius bill
skarsgard would be a perfect joker
with the third photo yet another
instagram user commented i so want
skarsgard to be the next joker
elsewhere in the comment thread one user
simply wrote creepy with three clown
emojis tucked on overall it's safe to
say that grey has convinced us that
skarsgard would fit right into the role
sure he's not the only actor the artist
has reimagined as joker johnny depp
crispin glover and jim carrey also get
the transformation treatment but grey's
vision of skarsgard as a bone-chilling
criminal is arguably one of the most
convincing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one